dans la boutique au milieu des dépôts de
divers créateurs ils trônent fièrement
ses poufs et de pneus sont l'oeuvre de
frédéric en octobre 2020 après une
formation en tapisserie cette ancienne
monitrice éducatrice de 41 ans en
reconversion s'est installé dans la
commune et a lancé son commerce
forcément sensible à tous les problèmes
environnementaux qu'il ya je me suis dit
que devrait utiliser les pneus et de
créer un objet décalé en plus avec le
côté récupère côté un peu traditionnelle
et casa tapisserie sa peau est sympa
une fois les pneus l'avait la
jurassienne s'occupe ensuite de les
peindre une matière première récupérée
grâce à des particuliers ou chez des
professionnels
des pneus qui vont avoir voilà qui vont
commencer à être très abîmée forcément
je veux pas les prendre parce qu'elles
vont manquer de solidité aussi et puis
après ben moi je m'amuse aussi avec les
formes les gabarits le dessin sur
l'écran aussi que ma muse associé à mes
tissus tout est fait à la main dans son
atelier frédéric manie la scie sauteuse
et la ponceuse afin de fabriquer un
socle en bois
j'ai préparé donc trois morceaux que je
vais assemblée
dans du bois de chêne en fait qui est du
bois c'est du bois en fait qui a
déclassé la six est coupée dans une
sorte de mousse avant que le tissu
soient tendus grâce à des agrafes est
ornée de cloud pour le moment seuls des
poufs et des tables basses ans ne sont
commercialisés mais l'artisane a de la
suite dans les idées